So we are in a full dystopia at this point
in time.
Yesterday, I already told you Donald Trump
went to the Rose Garden.
He gave an authoritarian nightmare of a speech
where he says he will fight governors by deploying
the military to enforce the law in their states.
The legal fight is Posse Comitatus Act versus
Insurrection Act.
We've already talked about that, certainly
at its face.
The idea that we need to fight protests about
law enforcement using too much force by scaling
up the amount of force used by law enforcement.
That's crazy.
We've already talked about that.
But then we get into the propaganda of this.
Donald Trump had protesters tear gassed and
dispersed with horses to clear the way for
Donald Trump to walk to St. John's Church
in Washington, D.C. and be photographed holding
up a Bible.
He was asked.
Mr. President, is that your Bible?
And he said, it is a Bible.
Of course, it's not Trump's Bible.
Trump is not religious.
This is merely pandering in front of the church.
This was done in a completely just sickening
obvious.
Brazen attempt to propagandize, but in order
to get over there.
Here is video of the protesters and here you
will hear the bangs going off.
You will see the gas start to rise.
Hey, he takes the propaganda seriously for
sure.
Here are members of the press being shooed
away as Donald Trump walks over to the cathedral.
Let's go, right.
Oh, my God.
We got to go right.
Go right.
And then here's an overhead view of the entire
crowd being aggressively dispersed, including
with tear gas.
Because the leader Trump must get to the church
to hold someone's Bible, bringing out the
horses.
You're going to hear some of the flash bangs
at the start of this video.
And so then here is Donald Trump calling over
his press secretary and a couple of others
and standing there and sort of at some point
Trump says, OK, the propaganda event is over.
And this is one of the most awkward video
clips I've seen in a long time.
The greatest country in the world.
Thank you very much, everybody.
Keep it nice and safe.
So everybody there in that photo op.
People who should be people who should be
unemployed.
Come January, if we do our job in November.
Now, by the way, just one other thing from
earlier here was Trump's Rose Garden statement
just minutes before walking over to St. John's,
having protesters tear gassed and dispersed
with horses.
You can hear explosions going on in the background
while Trump is speaking.
He will not have died in vain.
But we cannot allow the righteous cries of
peaceful protesters to be drowned out by an
angry mob.
The biggest victims of the riot.
That is not thunder.
You are hearing, my friends.
Those are flash bangs going off to disperse
protesters in advance of Trump walking over
to St. John's Cathedral.
This is where we are.
It's incredible how far we have fallen since
that horrible day, November of 2016.
And I've been you know, I've been talking
about hyper normalization.
I've been talking about desensitization.
It happens a little bit at a time.
But now when you go back and think of that
day when Donald Trump was inaugurated, we
have fallen so so far.
Now, if you need a reminder of how not religious
Trump is, if you needed him, a reminder of
how the Bible and the church are just props
for the president.
Remember this video for the camp from the
campaign where Donald Trump making it abundantly
clear he doesn't know a damn thing about the
Bible.
He doesn't care about the Bible.
You mention the Bible.
You've been talking about how it's your favorite
book.
And you said, I think last night in Iowa,
some people are surprised that you say that.
I'm wondering what one or two of your most
favored Bible verses are.
I wouldn't want to get into it, because to
me, that's very personal.
You don't want to talk about the Bible is
very personal.
I don't want to get into that.
I don't want to get into the know I write
means a lot to you that you think about or
cite.
The Bible means a lot to me.
But I don't want to get into specifics, even
to cite a verse.
No, I don't want to do that.
Every Old Testament guy does probably equal.
I think it's just an incredible the whole
Bible is an incredible joke.
Very much so.
They always hold up the order of the day.
I say my second favorite book of all time.
But I just think the Bible is just something
very special.
This has to stop.
This has to stop for our sake.
It has to stop for the world's sake.
It has to stop for our futures sake.
Trump doesn't even attend church.
It's not even his Bible aggressively and violently
dispersing peaceful protesters with horses
and flash bangs and tear gas so that he could
hold up someone's Bible and take advantage
of just a disgusting.
I mean, this is this is like Soviet style,
North Korea style propaganda that Donald Trump
is brazenly crafting in front of our very
eyes.
And we have to end it.
We have to end it.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Thrilled to see more and more folks listening
to the daily audio podcast of the show.
If you watch on YouTube, you may not know
that you can go on I tunes or Stitcher or
Google Play podcast, whatever you want and
get our daily audio podcast.
Do it.
It's a great way to consume the show in addition
to the YouTube clips.
Let me know your thoughts about this propaganda
on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we'll be right back.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.
All right, we have so much to get you today
that I will take no more than 15 seconds just
to say thanks to David Samuels and Nicholas
Guzman.